seelix water-damaged after being outside
all night I can't believe it's even on
oh Clark has a friend named Chloe who
might be able to help she really loves
weird texts up like this um she even has
this whole wall of weird okay I have no
idea what any of that means but send her
zip drive of everything we find just
kind of mutated what is it I call it the
wall of weird so do you think oh my god
you are friends with Chloe Sullivan what
happened to her I mean she was the
rising star of The Daily Planet like she
always dreamed and now it's like she
just vanished like someone found out
that she knew too much looks like
somebody took a bite out of Chloe's
conspiracy cookie I'm sorry to
disappoint you but Chloe couldn't make
it
mom
mom I'm sorry honey I'm not your mother
I imagine Noel Neil of the FBI I'm sorry
you just look so like my mother for a
second I thought I guess I just had one
of those faces it's an asset for my line
of work hey everybody we got to talk
about that Smallville crossover with DC
TV so if there was any question now I
think you know people assume multiverse
theory that it's out there somewhere
this canonically ties the events of
Smallville to DC TV that means the flash
arrow and Supergirl so I know it's a
little bit confusing with the way they
talk about Clark's friend Chloe and
obviously there's probably some of you
that may not have seen Smallville so you
don't know about the wall of weird so
I'll explain the logic behind that but
there was also some other Superman stuff
going on in this because it's the
Supergirl TV series so naturally there's
already a lot of related Superman things
going on but if you're just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything there's giveaway stuff
that I'll explain at the end of the
video too because we have crossover
stuff and Justice League happening this
week so the important stuff first I'll
explain you know what Smallville is in
the wall of weird but most of you
probably remember what was going on with
that TV series and I included that clip
for context anyway so what the TV show
is saying is that everything that
happened on Smallville during the course
of that show happened within earth 38
now obviously multiverse Theory there's
probably versions of Smallville out
there and the multiverse that are a
little bit different but they were very
explicit that Chloe Sullivan is a
character on earth 38 she's still alive
she had a wall of weird she was Clark's
friend growing up so even if you want to
assume multiverse theory that you know
maybe there were some small iterations
that were a little bit different
obviously Tyler hoechlin is the version
of Superman we've seen on this TV show
not Tom Welling so they fudge it just a
little bit but they're basically saying
that the events of Smallville happened
within the DC TV multiverse you know
whereas previously as a fan you just
kind of have to assume like hey maybe
we'll see it in there somewhere
maybe like when they go to different
earths and sometimes they flash images
from the old TV shows like we saw a
picture of John Wesley Shipp in his 90s
Barry Allen flash costume but we know on
the TV show we've seen him as Jay
Garrick from earth 3 so it's a
completely
different person a different costume so
obviously they've had Erica Durance on
for the last season playing a version of
supergirls mother they had a different
actress playing Elora the first couple
of seasons she had to leave so they
recast the role and it was like hey why
don't we bring a Smallville actress in
wouldn't it be cool if Lois Lane from
Smallville was actually a Laura zor-el
from this reality so it gets a little
meta and then I put that tag at the end
where she mistakes her for her mother
and she's like no no no my name is Noel
Neill I'm with the FBI the cool thing
about that is that Noel Neill was the
actress who played Lois Lane on the
1950s George Reeves
Superman series so like I said there's
always a ton of Superman Easter eggs on
the TV shows but foreign away this is
the closest we've gotten to actually
like literally seeing Smallville stuff
happening on the DC TV shows even
Michael Rosenbaum and Tom Welling have
admitted that the producers have tried
to get them to come on the shows before
in different roles because usually when
they bring the actors from previous TV
shows on they're not playing versions of
the characters they played on the
original series so like if Michael
Rosenbaum came on maybe they would try
to do a Lex Luthor thing but they would
probably try to bring Tom Welling on is
a slightly different version of Superman
or some twist on that but if you ever
get into an argument with a friend about
whether or not Smallville is connected
to DC TV now you can actually point them
to this scene and say yes it is
absolutely 100% connected so I know
obviously everybody wants to see Tom
Welling in a version of the Superman
character but I don't know when they can
bring Superman back because of all the
Justice League stuff happening the
movies do complicate the ability of the
TV shows to use some of those big a-list
characters but if you don't watch
Supergirl I'll do a catch-up video
before the big four and I cross over to
explain we know what's going on with the
characters big tip off this season is
that they're doing Legion of
super-heroes ma Nell is coming back and
they've already cast versions of
Brainiac 5 in Saturn girl
let's hope Brainiac 5 is a little
friendly so like we're basically getting
the légion characters mon l will come
back after being stuck in the future so
they'll explain what's going on with the
legion in the DC TV universe the funny
thing is is now that we know that it's
connected to the events of Smallville
they did a legion episode on Smallville
there's a legion ring in the fortress of
solitude
that means the Clarks ring that we saw a
couple seasons ago is that ring from the
events of Smallville so I just love the
way that they so the logic up and if you
ever want to meet the rest of the Legion
just put this ring on
I've reprogrammed it for time travel
only no flights not yet so if you have
questions about how it's connected just
post them in the comments below
obviously this is developing things so
they'll try to work in more Easter eggs
as they go along however long supergirl
stays on the TV show they'll continue to
reference Superman stuff Smallville
stuff anything that's connected to the
Superman mythos
but speaking of Justice League stuff I'm
allowed to post my full review video
Wednesday night really late it'll be
like 11 p.m. so that's when that will
post obviously I'll post my flash
episode after that airs tonight so whole
bunch of DC Comics stuff happening this
week in the punisher all those episodes
drop on Friday so I'll start doing
Easter Egg videos for that this weekend
so just be sure you turn alerts on so
you don't miss any of the videos it's
gonna be a really good week for comic
book lovers congratulations to the
latest flash ring giveaway winner a
brahim god please private message me so
I can get your contact details there'll
be a new round when I post that flash
video later tonight so while you wait
for everything click here for the new
crossover trailer and you can click here
for my non-spoilery Justice League
reaction thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight